it was a stunning experience I've still
not recovered that's what happens when
you work with him he was uh he was
magnificent
he was breathtaking I had a man love for
him I had three months of wardrobe
fittings before we even began and sword
fighting lessons in a German and Irish
and then we shot for a year
I loved Ireland I thought it was a
wonderful place but there were a are a
incidences going on and we were a
British company we had to change all our
plates on our car I wore in hiring I
were an American flag shirt around you
so they not confused me with the actual
Irish and they were threatening they
were threatening and they did threatened
Stanley's family and they even came to
the door and the maid said don't let
them in those aren't painters they said
we're here to paint we're here to paint
and she said they're not painters don't
let them in so he was on he jumped on a
ship and fled and fled back to England
he is he used the alias Robert Newton
and he said we'll have to real start the
picture again back in England we're out
of here so I thought I had a little time
so I fled to Paris and two days later
they said we're ready we're ready to
shoot in two days the company moved to
Salisbury we had to be dressed and ready
in our costumes and everything at dawn
because he said oh I can't I can't
design the shot unless you're exactly in
fit and ready and in costume well it's a
great film and a really wonderful
performance and I love particularly the
performance of yours the scene way
you're in the hospital I think you're
and you break down my son was dead or
dying yeah and we shot that at long lete
and Longley has a zoo the zoo had
monkeys and the monkeys were always
chattering and so I'm trying to tell my
son who wants to hear a story about
battles I was in in the Seven Years War
but the monkeys which shouldn't be
around Longley right yes no it happened
it's not the right it's the wrong sound
so his idea was get them a lot of
bananas and they will stop chattering
and they'll eat their bananas so instead
what we heard was because he gave too
many bananas and they were all violently
ill this is an interesting statement
they showed tonight of us in the
carriage because the horses made a
clip-clop sound and it hurt the dialogue
in the stay in the in the carriage so he
had the crew pull the carriages along
the highway now when you do a scene with
Stanley and Malcolm certainly knows a
scene takes at least a day one scene one
day and so as we shot during the course
of the day I would look out the window
and I would see crew members oh look
there's electric falling to the side
there go the grips boom bloom
I'll get you away he taught he we worked
with the acting with the acting part of
the picture because I knew that he had
grown up with Stanislavski and I knew
that the group theater and the New York
style of working was in his craw so I
have a scene in which I have been heroic
and I'm getting a reward of golden
doubloons you get instead of a medal you
get money and I and I thank the regiment
and I thank the captain and he said come
here he said gee right gee you're doing
it a little bit like your academy award
acceptance speech
do it more like Glen Ford I knew exactly
what he meant